because I sort of just very very briefly
lose it i am going to construct the step
graph for this whole therapy asst car
park at how would you toss and then
we're just going to be pre-filled a
simultaneous presence so that over the
next ablaze you can start work on it
uses okay so here's what i've gone out
my welcome to the sea now you can see
and insert them let's have a look and
what we're going to compare these two
days right I've got a I've got two from
quantities the night as you can hear
Eliza do you remember do you remember
when I showed you this and I said the
reason why we're doing this now do you
remember what the reason was cuz we
can't this week atlas
so what that means is we want to use
this time really effectively the clock
is ticking literally I really like to be
able to get to this point you remember
how you felt after the 81 and when a lot
of you got your marks back you're like a
freakin nailed that test it's because
you're welcome here yes we won't be well
prepared unless we get here is that a
reasonable thing to aim at should we try
again did you try again mm-hmm he's over
here okay yes I like I would guarantee
that the other I don't know what is the
simplest things that things I ya know i
can guarantee we'll talk about the
content that will go into the ap1 at the
right time when i give out the
notification for you guys which we
advocate okay in fact can we be your
first lesson look after care people
happy notification all right now I'm
going to show you a lot me to have your
rule there with a set of axes just like
mine how to construct this from scratch
and how I go back keep it up okay you
can see I've got two different
quantities I want to compare that's what
we use these corner axes for right and
there is a kind of linear relationship
between but it changes in sooo progress
so what would you like me to put on my
dependent and independent axes on my
horizontal and vertical lines there what
do you think yeah which which do you
think is going to be the independence
yeah I think time is independent right
and clearly cost depends on time right
so therefore I'm going to label just
like you should down the volume here
this is our time axis okay that makes
the vertical axis team cost I trigger so
I've got my independent of my dependent
one set up then you can see
I need to leave it somebody's because
like like time as it is a minute seconds
Alice that actually does matter right so
I'm going to go for hours over here and
don't ok today now I will point out as
well I hope your scenes in the grass
where instead of saying dollars they'll
say like thousands of dolls because
you're ensuring some large quantity of
money ok so do please pay attention to
the axles and what units they using okay
all right now where we go from there we
now want to think about what as you step
up like literally step up according to
time how much have you paid you can see
I've got some numbers here what do you
think makes sense is the last value to
have on your horizontal axis now you can
see how many up were here 1 2 3 4 5 I've
put an extra one on the end here you'll
see why in a second because this
actually is a little bit unusual there
are other situations which happened i'm
going to outline the minister on the
vertical axis we have to choose now
there are some awkward numbers here with
already notices okay so you probably
want to choose some nice round numbers
that gives you an appropriate top value
what looks like an appropriate time
value for this nice and round say
anything nea you would be perfect right
we definitely include everything under
there I mean I suppose we could make it
77 which makes it awkward so I'm going
to call that 80 and I have ten dollar
you can set up so you can leave all
those I'm just going to put in every
second one because I think that'll be
enough to see what's going on
now at this point we can do our steps
you can see the second you enter right
doesn't matter if you stay there one
minute five minutes or 59 minutes you're
paying this amount eleven dollars right
so come over to your axes you just want
to be right above eye level like this
right about ten matter now you'll notice
I haven't put any start or end on this
actual little interval that up foot here
right I want to know though where my get
a girl when I have my next line for one
to two hours I've got 22 that's
something like this but you can see if I
spend exactly one hour in there it's had
an ambiguous right which is why we
introduce this new annotation which do
you think the car park and charge you if
you're available exactly one out the
home clearly if you have charge of the
highway because the house always wins
they're always trying to make more money
so therefore it's this value that counts
not that one okay so you see Miss field
and this field and holler circles before
it means this is the value that matters
not this one well but what about 59
minutes and 15 seconds well because in
the same way once you've entered the
second you get into the car park is
still paying so that's why there's also
still sucking here and then the pattern
just continues I put the rest of my
steps in and I just want to make sure
that I'm good with my scale so 33 looks
like it's going to be about there 44
60 that's good if you lovely yeah you
see I'm not the only one crazy yeah and
now I'm going to last for here now I'm
just going to make a slight modification
to this because actually this is usually
what happens in your life five to six
hours that haven't said anything about
what happens after the sixth hour like
what would you expect it happen I am
pretty confident they're just going to
keep on charging you that same amount
part of the way that you can do after
the context is almost ticket if you lose
your ticket they charge you this why why
why doesn't yeah you could have been
there for any number of hours and say
who I lost my ticket I was here for now
you don't really they're not gonna trust
you on that they will charge you the
maximum amount which is why I think it's
reasonable to then concluded seventy
sevens right they need to talk i'm gonna
put it out there rather than ending for
however much longer you spend in the car
park they'll continue talking in that
rail just like it was for last so that's
the way that works ok step guys are not
confusing you just need to read the data
carefully and construct them we can